ils étaient 15 sur la ligne de départ en
2017 ou roar bergé s'était imposé pour
le compte de la république en marche
dans la 10e circonscription des yvelines
une victoire au second tour des
élections législatives face au député
sortant de l'époque jean frédéric
poisson à cinq mois du nouveau scrutin
la parlementaire n'a pas encore annoncé
si elle serait candidate pour un
deuxième mandat cette question c'est
répondrait au bon moment et le bon
moment c'est après l'élection
présidentielle
et moi je souhaite que président de la
république soit à nouveau candidat je
ferais sa campagne à 100% même plus et
je ferai tout pour qu'il soit réélu
parce que je considère que c'est la
bonne personne au bon moment et que si
j'ai pu agir en faveur de mon territoire
c'est aussi parce que j'avais ce
président de la république avec la
réindustrialisation attractivité
mobilité seront parmi les enjeux de la
prochaine campagne selon la députée
sortante dans cette circonscription de
120 mille habitants l'identité du
territoire est essentiellement rural a
également une place prépondérante
revient pas habité par hasard dans une
de ces cinquante et une communes de ce
territoire c'est non pas la défense
d'une identité en mode village gaulois
et ne font que rien ne bouge mais c'est
comment cette identité elle est une
force pour les habitants de ce
territoire services publics agriculture
aménagement du territoire toutes ces
thématiques doivent être prises en
compte au travers de l'écologie déjà en
lice en 2017 david j tiennent encore
rien décidé un nouveau profil pourrait
conduire la candidature d'europe
écologie les verts en alliance avec
d'autres mouvements de gauche l'élu
d'opposition à rambouillet croit en les
chances des victoires dans une
circonscription qui a été sous bannière
écologistes entre 2010 et 2012 c'est un
trait à un territoire sur lequel on est
implanté depuis depuis longtemps sur
lequel on nous idée
ne font que progresser ces dernières
années et vous l'avez constaté on arrive
deuxième force politique derrière les
républicains lors des derniers des
derniers scrutins c'est vraiment le
programme écologiste qui est adapté à la
situation environnementale climatique à
la situation de la de la biodiversité et
que tout ça ça se décline dans des
propositions très concrètes c'est une
dixième circonscription le combat des
gilet jaune a trouvé aussi incertaine et
qu il ne serait donc pas impossible de
voir émerger plusieurs candidatures
citoyenne l'une d'elles pourrait être
conduite par michael le saunier
fondateur du collectif des marcheurs
cueilleurs qui réfléchit à se lancer
dans la bataille des législatives
ancien soutien d' emmanuel macron est
proche d'aurore berger il se dit déçu
des promesses de renouvellement
politique et souhaite porter l'idée d'
écologie positive je trouve que l'offre
politique n'est pas satisfaisant pour le
concitoyens et pour les côtoyer tous les
jours pour était dense sur le terrain je
me rends compte qu'ils attendent autre
chose ils attendent qu enfin cela soit
des des citoyens devenus un peu d'eux
alors de la base assez péjoratif mais
voilà des vrais citoyens engagés qui en
fait est celle de porter au niveau
politique de nouvelles idées à droite
pour reconduire la circonscription les
républicains pourraient investir à un
cabri la mère d'orson ville et
conseillère régionale a confirmé atv 78
qu'elle pourrait être candidate
reste à savoir ce que va faire l'ancien
député jean-frédéric poisson en poste
jusqu'en 2017 en alliance avec l air le
président de via la voix du peuple
soutient désormais et les amours pour la
présidentielle les élections
législatives elles se tiendront les 12
et 19 juin prochains